[Music]
gasps is one of the stars of the popular
Showtime series shameless let's take a
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow you know what I have to say that
clip was your show is so great and it's
got so much for me some of that that
clip actually had me worried for you it
was kind of an intense clip and
depicting very realistic road rage you
have you experienced what I did you have
road rage when you drive here in LA it's
not hard to have road rage when you're
driving in LA but no I don't I'm just a
very distracted driver
I get very distracted very easily not
with texting or anything but yesterday I
was driving down Wilshire and I got very
distracted I was I almost rear-ended a
woman in front of me because there was a
food truck it was called Angie's weiners
Angie's women well what was so just
talking about it was this the the the
marketing for Angie's weiners was this
woman in this pinup outfit like very
buxom yeah big big keep doing this big
boobs yeah big boobs and the slogan
which was in red on big on the side of
the truck said the biggest wieners in
the hottest buns and as I was driving
past I saw this sign and really started
thinking about the marketing behind it
just yeah does that make me want to eat
a hotdog and then I looked up at the
split second was like oh my god there
will be a very embarrassing reason for a
car at ya and the police come and you're
filling out the report but you know we
actually heard about this and we looked
up the company this is the sign yes this
is Angie's Reiner's but it's the biggest
weiners and the hottest buns not in the
hottest
so what's your problem Oh wieners buns I
don't know that's an odd Mart so you're
saying that's a bad marketing campaign I
think guys just see the woman and the
hotdog and here we neurs and bonds know
women are more sophisticated I mean I
had got me interested though yeah it got
your attention it got you talking about
it on national television
you're welcome Angie's weiners yeah so